est ce qu'on peut faire entrer celle
qu'il a rencontrée en tunisie c'est
cyrine cyrine qui la rencontre tunisie
qui est avec nous ce soir
syrine fait contrer syrie merci merci
syrie qui est avec nous ce soir
syrine merci d'être là apparemment ces
motos vous entendez le mot tony vous
m'entendez tout va bien ouï dire que
vous êtes magnifique merci c'est vrai
que vous avez rencontré maxime gainey
c'était lors de cette caméra ka-shing
vous êtes resté en contact tous les deux
oui oui c'est vrai qu'on peut vous
enlever des choses allaient très bien
alors via les comédiennes vous avez
cliqué maxime kenny et puis ensuite vous
êtes restés en contact
oui savez et vous vous échangé beaucoup
tous les deux oui un peu vous l'aimez
bien beaucoup beaucoup
mabrouk à lesquielles ou laid ça
sarah sarasar à sa façade est ici ce
soir et maxime cyrine a quelque chose à
te dire tu habites en tunisie où tu
habites ici
les deux les deux d'accord donc il
habitera un petit peu d'entretien n'est
pas nouveau cousins ont fait rentrer un
nouveau est-ce que maxime gagné près les
chéris su que maxime gainey a quelque
chose à dire à siri est belle
maxime est là on va faire entrer maxime
tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'enjeu est là qui sont venus
les
[Musique]
vrai
toi
[Applaudissements]
alors cyril genty très grosse cote quant
à lui ce qu'a fait maxime bravo maxime
en tout cas maxime mercier aux danseuses
merci à nos danseuses
merci l'échelle maxim's et cyrine que tu
as connu il ya quelques jours
maxime maxime et cyrine maxime tu as
quelque chose à dire à cyrine je crois
que ça doit être quelque chose pour une
quelque chose il a écrit quelque chose
les chéris maxime gainey a préparé
quelque chose pour cyrine maxime
j'ai que ça sera votre pape est un nazi
si riner quand je t'ai rencontrée j'ai
tout de suite su que du serait ma petite
fille chat quand je te regarde dans les
yeux
tu fais de moi un homme heureux je rêve
de faire un couple et poissons ce soir
soit prête est joué
c'est dit c'est fait
un bout de chemin ensemble
[Applaudissements]
matthew et on essaie d'accepter de faire
un bout de chemin
alors maxime parce que vous connaissez
tu peux donc là un petit bout de chemin
c'est quoi un bout de chemin
c'est un bout de chemin c'est ce qu'on
peut lire des deux qui s'est jusque là
bas je sais on peut vivre au jour le
jour
voir ce que l'avenir nous réserve était
entre autres à ce point là ouais
franchement qu'on s'échange bas en mai
on peut glisser changer parce que j'ai
j'ai changé peut-être de venir au
téléphone donc mac c'est maxime très
courageux en tout cas tu as fait c'est
drôle tu vas quand même un peu vite
c'est pas grave et il faut prendre le
train quittant goutta voilà faudrait
prendre l'avion mois pour elle réside
alors si rim tu va nous dire ce que tu
en penses
est ce que tu as à répondre à maxime
merci en tout cas je suis fier de ton
motion il faut seulement c'est parfois
alors maxime
on n'a pas bien compris ce que vous
vouliez pas ce que vous avez rencontré
cette jeune fille est direct vous le
ferez une bague
je rappelle que si les mariages dans
cette émission c'est sa porte rarement
centre regardez gilles verdez ça fait
huit ans qu'il a fait ça génère et fatou
n'a toujours pas dit oui
qu'est ce qu'il ya même moi je n'ai
jamais eu une balle de sa part mais vous
êtes des choses mais en plus quel
rapport est ce qui vous happe et chaud
ben non mais il aurait pu essayer en
offrant une bague maxime voilà bien fait
avec beaucoup je te le dit génériques
même que mais avec mu maxime donc tu as
fait une déclaration d'amour à cyrine
mais qu'est ce que tu cherches qu'est ce
que tu veux je cherche simplement à
officialiser une belle rencontre on
s'est rencontrés dans le cadre d'une
expérience un peu télévisuelle je me
suis dit pourquoi pas le dire au grand
jour et depuis quand même quelques
années que je côtoie chercher un nouveau
film case et donc je voulais vous
montrer une bonne fois pour toutes que
il est possible d'avoir un petit peu de
courage de le faire en direct est de
prouver que l'on peut bien aller un peu
plus loin tu parles pas de mariage
accord est plutôt d'une union et
et pourquoi pas le fait de le faire dans
la joie la bonne humeur syrie ne pas
partir en tunisie je crois là pour aller
rejoindre sa famille donc on va voir si
vous êtes sélectionné déjà pour la
tunisie maxime mai syrine juste avant qu
est ce que vous avez à dire à maxime
alors les sentiments sont réciproques
je peux pas te dire oui je peux pas te
dire non mais t'es toujours le bienvenu
en tunisie moi tu travailles à l'office
du tourisme
[Applaudissements]
parce que ça va tout l'air d'être un
non non ça n'est pas non ce n'est pas en
fait tu es sous le charme de maxime
oui mais pour l'instant tu as envie qui
te prouve plus en tunisie de quitter
après c'est sa petite affaire cessante
irin oui donc cyrine maxime
j'espère qu'il va venir en tunisie et
sylvie en tunisie il fera tous je dis
bien tout pour te séduire
je sais pas quoi mais lady g je serai là
en coach franchement alors je vous dire
il peut pas trouver meilleure cote voilà
l acte à vous dire la coach sème la
somair profession à la base
excusez moi syrine donc c'est ça tu vas
partir en tunisie
oui et par maxime va tout faire pour te
séduire il ya une petite chance ou pas
une petite ouverture
bien sûr grandement il faut voir yamaha
team est ce qu a déjà eu un petit bisou
on trouve juste pour savoir non pas
encore mais ça ne saurait tarder c'est
en cours et sa mère passe vraiment bien
il ya un vrai bon feeling ouais syrine
que d'accord c'est ton style de mec
maxime cette affaire s'épargner oui ni
non
c'est vraiment mon style vraiment j'ai
chopé un truc
allez faites moi qui ai fait beau la vie
et tu la reverra en tunisie
contact